this is from my modern Netcom inner
monologue people are shocked to discover
that not everyone has an inner monologue
so the general idea my understating of
what inner monologue is is like when you
periodically talk to yourself about like
just like thinking about concepts plans
actions so I will I think it's fair to
point out to a certain degree I actually
think in in different ways and different
things so I've experienced this weird
thing where I'll think in words and
concept at the same time so I can think
on like two tracks yeah I can also I can
also imagine music images ideas and
words at the same time okay
I wonder if this is just about people's
ability to think in at the city like
think in words some wonder if it's the
power of the beanie well this is
actually something interesting people
don't know that my dad was an
archaeologist
did he wear any no he discovered the
beaning ancient tomb I mean when he
brought it back
banditos were trying to track down the
power they were there working as
mercenaries for the Soviets during the
Cold War
1986 yes and so he he hid the be my crib
and kicked it into the into a river
where it floated away was discovered by
my my adoptive parents and they put the
beanie on my head and my eyes started
glowing and they're like oh I'm kidding
by the way don't worry no this anyway
happen the point is what I'm trying to
say is that I think in a bunch of
different ways yeah and I wonder if this
is just some people don't think they
think and so I've talked some people
about it and they say that you know they
like maybe they just think in in ideas
and concepts so it's not that they're
not thinking at all but it's kind of a
bias because you think with language to
yourself you assume that because they
don't they're lesser or NPCs right but
the joke I would make is that this is
proof NPCs are real people who aren't
actually thinking to themselves or an
inner monologue because I wonder like
the concept of an inner monologue
doesn't necessarily mean language it's
your sentience your understanding of
yourself it's you right like you're you
a that guy are you sentient he was like
no well so people who may miss the
context I was talking to a friend about
this like 14 years ago and I
I was walking down the street I was like
I'll prove it to you like this idea of
of simulation theory and I asked a guy
hey hey buddy are you sentient and he
just looks at me and goes no and then
just walks away so I don't think you
knew what it meant I think you just
caught him off guard I say dumb stuff
when I'm sure sure
so well let's let's let's read this
story and see what it says but the so
actually let me give a little bit more
context you may you may be familiar with
the NPC me NPC me and it means
non-player character the way to explain
an NPC would be like if you're playing a
video game an RPG and there's an
innkeeper and he can only say a few
preset things he never actually talks to
you but one way I explain to people is
like some people are play video games
right but everybody's played Mario all
right you know when you in mario 1 you
get to the castle and you beat it and
there's toad and then the words appear
and he says thank you for saving me but
your princess is in another castle yep
Mario is controlled by you you know you
are playing the game and you control
Mario toad looks just like Mario does I
mean it looks different buddy's a little
person too but you know no one is
controlling toad
he's a non-player character yeah so
think about that way and then now now
move that up to real life imagine when
you met something ever meet someone and
they say like stock annoying repetitive
things oh yeah mm-hmm
oh yeah like when you watch TV like our
realities many times so these are the
NPC's mm-hmm I wonder if we could prove
that there are some people who just
don't think energy like mindless drones
hmm it'd be horrifying implications for
society hey you wanna read this one sure
let's see here let's go
all right people are shocked to discover
that not everyone has an inner monologue
hmm well have you ever had a
conversation with yourself one that took
place inside your head if so you are one
of the many that have an inner monologue
or an inner voice that narrates your
thoughts throughout the day but did you
know that many people have no such inner
dialogue while that may seem strange to
some it's equally odd for someone who
doesn't have an inner monologue to
imagine how that manifests itself that's
engineering it's like so it is equally
but hold on weird on the other side
they're like will you talk to your so
you have a monolith I do right and Lydia
do you I do a lot of questions at me too
well it's not like I'm you know thinking
like I
scrolling Mouse right now I'm picking up
my phone and calling my mother I'm it's
more like you got this this trick you
know like I'm not gonna say it out loud
but I'm thinking in my head like all
right I can do this
right yes yeah kickflip I know but I
like or think like all right I didn't do
that correctly but I can you know and
it's interesting I'm not necessarily
always saying it to myself but sometimes
I am like you got this like you got this
trick you know or this is just the first
thing that pops in my head but I'm also
visibly seeing myself what I'm supposed
to do to get it and that also helps you
know you know I was saying earlier that
like I can think I can I can like
imagine a sound an image yeah as well as
ideas and words I think that has to do
with the things I've like grown up doing
about playing music so I'd have to
imagine that the sounds and my to tune
my guitar by ear where I hear it and I
feel like yes that's right right I've
done video editing so I'd have to
imagine like the images of like what was
being produced and I I guess from
reading a lot doing the internet stuff
and like I used to program games when I
was little I would think in like words
like okay what do I need to do this and
so all of these different things come
together and manifest in this way like
when I'm skateboarding I will actually
think in like skateboard has its own
language so I'm definitely thinking
words and images and I'm physically
visualizing and imagining all the
movements that come with it physically
visualizing that's like what I've never
let me explain that better for I'm
imagining in my head slow motion what I
need to do to make a skateboarding trick
work right that's what I was talking
about break you know I cuz obviously I
didn't get it so I'm like alright what
am i what am I supposed to do to get it
right yeah and you know that's what I'm
thinking well let's let's read more this
is interesting all right said the topic
of inner speech has caused a stir on
Twitter after a user Kyle plant emoji
put out his own observation on the
matter quote fun fact some people have
internal narrative and some don't he
tweeted as in some people's thoughts are
like sentences they hear and some people
just have abstract nonverbal thoughts
and have to consciously verbalize them
and most people aren't aware of the
other type of person yeah I was seems so
weird to me yeah he like discovered it I
actually that's where I first heard it I
saw this this tweet back and forth
between him and one of his friends I
guess and they were talking about and he
was like his mind was blown yeah but
like the other person literally said the
things out loud like they it's not that
they could see it in their head or like
say it in whatever they were actually
going like alright I can do this I can
do this
alright I'm gonna it's not gonna land
this trick hold on the landing and all
that loud like they couldn't in turn
like you know that doesn't you know why
hmm there's a saying do you ever think
before you speak well they they don't
that's what it's saying so that's what
that person who he was talking to was
saying to him like no I I have to say it
out loud I have to like prep myself out
loud I say it out loud that makes sense
that's that confusion that you feel
right now is exactly what he was
explaining right he was like I don't get
it how do you not how can you not just
say words in your head and they're
saying like the other side of the coin
is it's equally confusing that they how
do you do it like how does that make any
sense well I don't understand the cause
of it there must be some middle ground
because sometimes I have a really clear
inner monologue and sometimes I don't
like I brought this up the other night I
was like I was washing my hands and I
was thinking about this because I was
asking myself questions about how it
could possibly be that some people don't
have an inner monologue I was like how
does this work do you think this is
possible that X Y & Z I was like oh my
gosh there's my inner monologue it was
really funny I think therefore I am
let's see so the phenomenon itself has
been debated for years by scientists
psychologists began looking into the
function of the inner speech in the
1930s it was a Russian psychologist Lev
Vygotsky
who suggested that it external
conversation can be internalized he even
proposes that this inner speech was
highly abbreviated and included a lot of
emissions the idea that of external
speech became internalized is also
supported by the evidence that it's the
same part of the brain
Broca's area that deals with both Wow
hmm so it's really interesting
interesting so if you if you have no
inner monologue
you should be out here give me that let
me do that so if you have no inner
monologue
should you be worried not really studies
show that some individuals never accept
and said at all while others only
experience it occasionally I'm confident
that inner speech is a robust phenomenon
and if you use a proper method there's
little doubt about whether or not inner
speech is occurring and in any given
moment interesting right
Russell Tia Hurlburt Hurlburt professor
of psychology at the University of
Nevada and I'm confident about the
individual differences some people talk
about it to themselves a lot some never
some occasionally it's interesting so
what you're saying is that they're NPCs
and the inner monologue is the supreme
brain and we rule yeah
it reminds me of Rick and Morty when
they go to the planet with like the
people of different nipples and they're
like you know the cone nipple and
they're in the and the spiral nipple
whatever and they like they find a
reason to be racist right like do you
have an inner monologue no to you on the
fight so I wonder though the way they're
framing it is like in defense of people
who don't have one I got to be honest
yeah I don't know anybody who doesn't
I don't either is it a weird thing I you
just said like they find a way to be
racist and they asked do you have an
inner monologue it's like I kind of what
else they're asking people because I
want to say hey do you have your mama
what do you rack your brain are you and
it's like and how do you wreck the brain
if they don't have anything and it's so
I don't have nothin in there but all
right I don't feign oh it's like every
sentence before I say it no obviously
not but I don't either
often I'm sitting here thinking in words
to myself going over ideas and concepts
there's a there's a memorization
technique that you can use different
kinds of memorization but I guess if you
don't have an inner monologue you can't
yeah so what there's there's a couple
things that I do I used to work in
fundraising and I could memorize a
16-digit credit card in one second of
looking at it like you flash it in front
of me I got it
Wow so what I would do is it's if a few
things photographic memory verbal memory
and like I guess written memory so I
would segment out portions so that I
would remember the image
I would remember I would say it to
myself and then I would remember like
the numbers as individual numbers it was
actually a really funny story and I'm
gonna tell it it's gonna get me in
trouble mom tells story anyway do it so
I was at a boost mobile I was talking to
me in troubles gonna get it's gonna get
this guy in trouble
and apparently Robin Williams had a
Boost Mobile account so one of the
employees was going through their
database and found the name and took the
number down because he thought he'd be
cool if he had it so I was getting like
actually knows a RadioShack there's a
long time ago this was like 14 years ago
okay and so this guy takes his phone I
was going there to put 20 bucks on my
boost mobile phone to get turned on or
whatever and I go in there and I'm
talking and this guy's talking to
somebody needs bragging he starts
bragging about how he got Robin Williams
phone number and so I'm standing there
waiting to pay and I go no I don't
believe you and he's like you don't
believe me and I was like nah you're
just blowing smoke and he goes oh yeah
he pulls it up and he holds it for about
a second and puts it away and I went
eight nine three seven twenty six five
four three one mmm-hmm and he went oh
dude dude dude no no no no and I put in
my phone right away I'm like thanks for
the number bro what and I I'm pretty
sure it was real did you try it
no I didn't yeah I didn't know but but
but I'll just say I have reason to
believe it was actually his number you
know so I was I was thinking about
something do you think that this inner
monologue ability I guess you know it's
an ability that some people don't have
has to do with IQ you know like the the
higher your IQ the more this brain
function this is why butter and now this
is why I brought up the memory why
wouldn't it though because my IQ is not
super high I don't think and I have an
extremely do not know what I know I
haven't checked hold on hold on hold on
yeah this is why I brought the memory
thing mm-hmm if you don't have an inner
monologue then you can't memorize things
the way I just explained I do right
saying so and having a high IQ you are
more likely to be able to do stuff like
that and for the record the average IQ
is is fairly low it is actually pretty
low so I mean you and I have had many
conversations IQ is average okay
brewer than you wouldn't think sure it's
ever the average I know your number the
average IQ person is not that smart
right typical to what most people assume
they are but I'm just curious what
average there's if there's some sort of
correlation between the two you know I
and what I was saying is we've had many
conversations right you're pretty
articulate you're pretty logical and you
know with it and I feel like you would
have a higher than average IQ you know
so a Jesus just wants to believe he has
a really high I know I'm not saying that
I I don't know I've never taken a test
you know but well I you of like 200 I'm
just putting I'm putting the questions
that's really crazy that's like a
hitting super super super genius I think
it's like going to 405 I think you're a
genius but okay no no I just want to
know if there is a correlation I'm not
talking about any I'd say yes oh I bet
there was yes I think that it comes down
it comes down to this there are people
who have inner monologues and lead
normal lives and they're people without
who go and buy all of the toilet paper
and fight with people in the aisles
boxing each other for toilet paper hmm
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you